[Music]
hey guys it's Greg here hey it's John
it's 2:00 in the morning we just got
back from Universal CityWalk IMAX and we
watched Logan
Logan the whole movie that's what he
does again it's the same exact film all
over again just X-Men Origins part two
Mor morigins X-Men
morigins H my so on isn't it the mic on
all right so this is just going to be
like a a non-spoiler talk uh we'll we'll
just cut right to the chase all right
we're not going to do some like here's a
rating system for you well actually no
this is a perfect time for me to use my
rating system it's pretty good maybe a
masterpiece definitely better than great
I'm putting my rating system out there
right away this film is a pure
Masterpiece there's only a couple of
nitpicky things I could think of by the
time the movie was done that came down
to two things that are really not a big
deal whatsoever well the thing about
there like there are things that you can
pick out of this movie and I know this
is going to sound like a cop out but
it's it's a movie that does so many
things well that like little
construction errors I don't really care
that much about you know what what I'll
tell you guys man like this film was
just it was mesmerizing like like we
don't have we didn't don't when we shoot
reviews we tend to like to think about
it for a day or two so we could like
really proper when we talk most we can
do is really communicate our feelings
right now this film had this strong
level of like so many adjectives like
despair desolate you said sparse yeah
it's kind of it's kind of uh it's very
Stark and it's very hot and it's very
deliberate you know in the way it's
paced and the way it moves along it's
very ruminator and in you know some
heavy [__] it is one of the best
I think it's the best X-Men film a B I
think it's one of the best comic book
movies I've ever seen because it's felt
like a film yeah a comic book film I
really I really think so it felt it
reached far beyond Way Beyond like just
a comic book movie this felt like an
actual just godamn good film the whole
time well yeah at least walking out of
this this is sort of like what I what I
personally just as a viewer like have
been hoping comic book movies could be
for a long time you know and certain
movies have done too uh and and it is
like a comic book film like you said it
is a Western and it is kind of sci-fi
but it's also really personal and really
you know human in a lot of ways and so
like it is a full-on passion project it
feels like it's not exactly the kind of
film where if you don't watch prior
X-Men films you you're like I feel like
this is one of those films where you
would have to have seen a few X-Men
films in order to truly appreciate that
yes absolutely that's if anything that's
like probably its only weakness to it is
that you have to see prior installments
besides that though this film man where
to begin with it uh I guess was start
with like Hugh Jackman is Logan this was
he he always does an amazing job even in
like the shitty movies he does a good
job but in this film like this is Oscar
caliber and I don't think it would get
Oscar consideration or even Golden Globe
consideration just because of the film
it's in he's done the RO so many times
who knows but going off of like what
this film does like I I described it to
John as like this film is him struggling
for one more breath the entire time it's
when you think of like DiCaprio and the
Revenant of a physical performance this
is a very physical demanding role not
Beyond just being jacked like this is a
very physically demanding role
emotionally you're just seeing Logan be
stripped down to Pure vulnerability yeah
I mean he's just surviving this whole
time and and same with Professor Xavier
too they're all just surviving in this
really kind of you know you said
desolate kind of desolate situation
they're like hold up in this little fort
and he's driving a limo yeah and like
you know they're they're saving up for
something but it just seems like a slog
and like you really feel the the day in
and day out of what Wolverine's life has
become you know what Logan's life has
become it's it's so interesting because
it's really character driven film that's
the beauty behind it yeah you walk out
of this film not thinking Wolverine but
Logan and then when it shows when it
says the title of Logan we won't give it
away but it's such an interesting moment
at the beginning of the film when it
says Logan that you're like this is a
very I can see why they're not calling
this wolverine 3 because this is like
Old Man Logan you know yeah yeah really
I mean it's yeah this is this just Dives
right into like his existential crisis
of yeah you know it's the furthest
possible extent and it's what does he
have anym to live for and so like it's
cool to have an actor like Hugh Jackman
who really seems like he cares about
this character it never seems like a
money grapp yeah exactly he seems like
he's genuinely invested in this and in
this movie that shines so brightly you
know he is he's you know I mean there's
there's a lot of it's not like slight on
the dialogue or anything but there is a
lot of stuff that's just played in his
face and his physicality and and there's
a lot of different physicality he has to
play in this movie we're used to like
serious brooding Wolverine and we know
he's great at the dark depths but it's
those weird moments of light where he
you see a genuine smile come across his
face yeah like uh cuz he he starts off I
Won't Give It Away actually but like the
first time you see him crack a little
smile when he's in the limo he's driving
those girls and something happens but
just even like that we like that is
something he might smile at like no
matter how [__] up this whole
situation he's in that is something he
would smile at or that scene they show
in the trailer where they're all at the
dinner table and like little touches
like that like the the times where the
movie just takes time to slow down and
give us some heart and meaning without
being like shoving emotion in your face
it's so natur there are times when he's
allowed to slip into being a normal guy
for a second and like you know usually
something happens pretty soon after that
but like you know
that's some of the most you know kind of
poignant stuff about this movie is like
those little moments those little
moments of life you know yeah because in
this in this world they're few and far
between you know like it's and that's
where that's where the Western element
comes in here too because like you know
Xavier and Logan they're they both don't
belong here and so they're just kind of
drifting now yeah and this you know this
movie just gives it all a shot of
purpose Xavier man Patrick Stewart a
whole new level to [__] Charles
Xavier than we've ever seen he is not
cool common collected Xavier in this
movie po Xavier anymore and and that was
something that that it did take me a few
minutes to at least uh get acquainted
with in this movie like there is a a
sort of tonal uh bell curve that you do
have to ride because you know the way
they talk to each other kind of off the
bat in this movie is very different you
like they're both swearing in each other
and like the dialog is different well
it's it's like in this their Dynamics
have changed whereas Xavier is always
watching after Logan and stuff and and
it's this time it's like Logan's really
watching after Xavier yeah yeah and so
it's such a different Dynamic and such
history felt it's it makes we're two of
the like yeah it's it makes the other
movies better get the tension of their
relationship because especially like
thinking back on it now and you know
like I'm sure watching it again like you
see like you know Logan's kind of dick
but you see why all these relationships
are so graded like they are because he's
the guy kind of holding this whole thing
together doing these kind of yeah sad
things every day you know like just to
get by like and just to keep people
alive and keep them moving and stuff
it's beyond like when the first like 20
minutes of this film you realize like
Logan ain't Isa like going on missions
right now he's just trying to you know
make some money and get [__] boat
like which is a place that guy can go
and we've seen him go before yeah
exactly and x23 Laura holy crap I
thought I thought hit girl was my
favorite little girl I can kill this is
my this might be my new favorite one man
she's she's really genuine like she's
she's great at it I mean like it's a
body language performance for sure like
most of the film she doesn't speak
that's a pretty sophisticated
performance you know like she's props to
her cuz she's terrific and the rage felt
real yeah she's like [__] up people
man holy [__] I was like that seems like
a really rful little girl like what
she's seen some [__] be to act like
children are supposed to be able to act
this
way and uh but it's captivating like
that's the thing is like it's an
ensemble piece just as much as it is
anchored by Logan and like the
performance of Patrick Stewart in the
performance of I I should remember her
name but the the girl plays Laura like
they're all distinct and they all have
you know yeah um and even the supporting
characters like that dude with Steven
Merchant dude Stephen Merchant killed it
he's when they said his name on the
opening titles I was like Stephen
Merchants yeah I had no idea and then
when he first showed up I was like okay
is he going to be like kind of a comedic
character and then I thought it like
making him like what Vision was in in
Civil War what I was getting at first
and then but yeah there but no they go
they go to depths with that guy yeah
like that's the thing is you learn what
everybody's life this is a thing that
takes the time to learn what everyone's
life is like now that more time has
passed like his I I loved that he was
able to do that because I don't know
like I always something just a personal
thing is like I always root for the
comedy guy who like gets a rle in
something like this and gets a chance to
shine dramatically like Simon Peg has
done that a bunch of times where I'm
like you can [__] act too and Steven
Merchant did that for me here where I
was he had more than just dialogue it
was like it was body language too a lot
in a lot of the eyes the facial
expressions of this character like he
really threw himself into this and I'm
like props to you man that's a good
performance Calibur calibar calbar
calbar sorry yeah calbar and then you're
talking about the one of the villains oh
yeah I the guy with the gold too like
the Winter Soldier arm yeah exactly that
dude like even he brought something in
that character cuz that's a character
that's easy to make like completely
forgettable and while like you know
they're a bigger fish than him at play
like he was still like this guy's still
hate him yeah I'm still like you've got
enough personality that I care to see
you you know go down cuz it's one of
those films where everything there's no
one there's no like fish out of water
scenario where you got someone being
introduced to everything it's one of
those movies that throws you into this
world yeah what I love about it is like
what was this like 10th X-Men movie or
something don't quote me on that I think
it's the 10th um but so there were so
many X-Men movies and none of them have
made me feel immersed none I've always
thought these are entertaining and
sometimes that's a pretty damn good film
sometimes I think that too but this was
the first time where I for I would
forget I'm in the theater yeah I would
forget I'm watching a movie like I'm
noticing like my mood is just shifting
and I'm locked in to this world that's
that's like toned down it feels like a
real world you know yeah yeah it really
did it did the same for me like it
really did pull me into to the point
where I wasn't sitting there and like
you know picking things out or whatever
and like uh yeah it it it it what was I
gonna say the last thing you said about
like the immersiveness oh I got a point
with that I remember your point when you
when you remember it yeah it'll come
back around all right cool my my my
point one of my things I love about it
like we haven't mentioned it cuz this
film was so much more than just an
R-rated X-Men movie yeah the violence in
it yeah this [__] BR it's brutal
flesh is tearing on people's faces like
it is nasty I think I might express some
concerns the first time we watched like
a red band trailer trailer for this but
like this did a great great job of
giving you everything you want out of an
R-rated X-Men movie but without making
it silly like it's yeah they take a
chance to show the realism across the
board cuz at first when you start
hearing a bunch of f bombs early in the
movie I thought it was a little thrown
off I was I that was the only time in
the movie where I was like it feels like
they're trying to shove the R rating in
my face right now yeah yeah but I I
quickly lost sight of that it's just a
different world at this point and for me
it's like I wonder how that will play
the second time now that I'm used to
them talking that way cuz it's just it's
not how we've ever heard them talk to
each other a PG-13 driven franchise it's
it's kind of surprising yeah and even
when he shows up and says like go [__]
yourself like in a way to me at least
that almost calls more attention than
the fact that they don't usually swear
like oh it's a special occasion so I
hear them swearing all the time is like
yeah you to kind of get used to it uh
but that's you know like this movie has
so many great details and and great
things wrapped inside of it because it
is like people keep saying Western and I
I do think that's a good description
because well it's very apparent that it
that it wants to be that it's that is a
futuristic kind of Western but it is but
it has like it really does even more
than in just the tone just like the way
you have a bunch of characters all
pointed at each other and each one is a
straight line intended to go through the
other like everyone's got a will
everybody needs something and you know
it's it's very much a tracking movie
it's like they're on the road they're on
the run you know it's immediate yeah
yeah definitely the violence as well
though like I
was it's it was more than just you know
like when you watch Deadpool and you're
like oh cool we're getting an R-rated
comic book movie yay and they're
swearing and it's but with here it's the
violence is yeah for sure it's
entertaining at the same time
though equally like cringy at times cuz
[Music]
the thing is like the the way the
violence comes into this movie the way
the action scenes come up it's like you
they do come at when the plot needs them
to like when the story needs them to so
you get the catharsis along with the oh
[__] cool you know so it's like you
really feel the release that you would
you know they they have a scene where
they like play like a clip from Shane
from because they're watching it from
the TV and it's a great resemblance
towards like I think of like there's
there's a movie I saw years ago it's a
clinta movie Unforgiven and there's a
character in there who who's a cowboy
and he just wants to be a badass cowboy
and he kills someone and then he's
haunted by the violent moment like he's
not what he thought killing would be
yeah and this movie portrays the
violence in a way where it's a major
dramatic effect it's not like anyone's
really like in despair like when they
kill someone but n there's times where
yeah there times it's a it's you can
tell it enhances the world and the
experience and
the suspense like when violence is
coming like At first it's like oh those
are cool but then when later scenes are
coming and there's violence it's kind of
like could puts you a little bit more on
edge yeah yeah I mean well because it's
it is that thing and and it it it's so
wonderful to me anyway that it makes
that choice to dig into it because it is
like this is about people who accept
that the violence is a part of their
world yeah and they are good at it yeah
but they don't like it you know like
it's it's that existential crisis of
like I don't want to kill anybody but I
have to to keep living what does that do
to somebody and we find that out we find
that out both in an old man and in a
child you know and that's that's what
makes that you know him and x23 like
that
relationship that Arc is [__] great
perfectly beautifully told their entire
couple weeks or whatever they spend
together in this movie uh is beautifully
told because it's because it's like you
know especially if you read the comics
you know who x23 essentially is but as
the film plays out it's never done in a
way where it's hamfisted it never it's
never done in a way that feels cliche or
like you can kind of see the direction
of where it's going to go but by the
time it gets there it feels natural
organic exactly how Wolverine will
respond to this whole thing you know
it's all it like they just they just
knew Logan so well they yeah this movie
this movie never felt like it was
conforming to something that the studios
were like you got to fit this in here it
really seemed like they got to make the
movie they wanted to make kind of feels
like an like an independent huge budget
film in away yeah and and a friend of
this one A friend of mine once pointed
this out to me he said like you know
like James mangle like he basically said
like I like his movies but I don't
really have like a there's not a
touchstone that makes them distinct to
me you know like like they're pretty
good but they're not he doesn't have
like a stamp that makes it his and this
was the first time where I was like this
dude laying down style cuz there are a
lot of different styles like it there
are a lot of different visual tones and
visual Styles and it uses you know the
sound and the images to make you to
really pull feelings out there are these
scenes that involve Professor Xavier
having these like seizures and those are
so jarring in the way that they shoot
them they're like hard to look at and
they're shrill and like it really goes
that extra out to make you feel the
things that these characters I actually
heard about the seizure scenes in an
interview and they they said that uh
they the cameraman would really shake
the camera yeah I believe and uh that
they and then for some of the moments
they would they would uh be pulling uh
Hugh Jackman like they had something
attached to him where they'd be pulling
so to fight against it oh wow yeah see
that's like got find you got to watch it
to see what we're talking about yeah but
yeah like when I when I when this got
done I was like yeah man like I I feel
like yeah you directed the [__] out of
this like you really made a movie that
you wanted to make and it's got your
personality on it you know like mad
respect for that tonight was a great
night at the movies yeah if you're not
doing anything this weekend or if you
are cancel it find time to watch Logan
if you can go to a legit iMac screening
like that that was part of the beauty of
it was like like it wasn't shot with
IMAX cameras but it was so worth it and
it's not even because it's like flashy
visual it's because there's some great
visuals in there but you really just
walk away thinking of the experience he
went on more than just it looked cool
and there was cool action and
Wolverine's funny at times like yeah
there's the comedy you want there's the
cool fights there's the added like oh
[__] Gore Factor there's like sniffles
through the roof in this
theater man I was it got to the point
where I was like looking around like
everyone everyone's crying saw John Cry
For The First Time in 10 years today
yeah I cried a couple times the third
time I cried I cried for real yeah I saw
leg tears then when the CB R there like
little smile on your face yeah no this
make me happy and like that's the thing
is like it's It's A Hard movie but it's
it made me feel happy inside when a
movie can do that cuz it it tells so
many awesome little arcs and has such a
tone and such a you know love for its
source material while not taking itself
like crazy seriously and there were
certain things that you know surprised
me like certain things happen that are
just sad that drive the point home where
you're like yeah you know yeah totally
and something something appeals to me
too about movies like this about dudes
who just like [__] give everything
for a like something they need to see
through like I always when somebody can
really pull that Arc off like it it
makes me feel warm ins St so I'm I'm
really glad that last year I said this
is the movie I was looking forward to
most in 2017 because it totally paid off
I'm so happy for them like like awesome
cool like welcome yeah yeah what a what
a perfect
it's been very much announced all over
the board that this is his last movie
and what a way to go out I really I'm
really happy that this was like the
final movie yeah yeah cuz that that was
a that was it's an experience it's got
heart and soul and all the cool [__] you
want to like it's it's an like I kind of
don't want to watch it again for a while
yeah because I just you can't beat that
first
time and it's also great the first time
is sorry to cut you off there but but
that is kind of like it's kind of like
when I watched uh I don't know [__]
it's like I saw Avengers pretty close to
each it's not the same thing as
Avengers what well yeah CU it's
different and that's that was the thing
that they they they do acknowledge the
comic books in this movie and that was a
touch that made me very happy because
weirdly makes it feel more like a real
world yeah and that's the thing is like
the whole I feel like the whole point
and it's you know it's it's nice we can
we can kind of talk about this with a
movie now is like this movie takes the
superhero movie and goes oh God yeah
what if we done you know like and and
that's a it uses that responsibility
really really well yeah you know dude
okay you guys you guys got to go watch
this movie it's Ser like I I know you've
heard everyone say how amazing it is and
uh you listen to them yeah there's a lot
of love in this this this this film is I
I consider like while you can find a few
flaws here or there they're very minor
they don't last long ever and when I say
they don't last long I mean they're very
brief moments that I can like go well
there was something kind of off about
this one little five seconds I saw but
other than that yeah I me there's you
know continuity sometimes or there there
were one or two scenes where I was like
I thought that scene felt like it wanted
to go in longer and then it would cut
away or something like that but perhaps
yeah I don't know I think they they
succeed on so many levels and the thing
is like it's for me like it's it's hard
hard to get excited nowadays you know
and and I worry a lot for these big
expensive movies because it's a lot of
money on the line and you know and a lot
of expectations on the line and stuff
like that and uh it's nice when like I
sat down in the chair before this and I
was like you know what I'm I'm just
excited to be here and like to be able
to to admit that sometimes it's hard cuz
you know like we see stuff that that's
kind of a let down here and there all
the time and uh it was nice to walk out
and be like yeah that completely
satisfied what I was hoping it could be
dude I had extremely high expectations
for this movie yeah I'm not going to
sugarcoat that I had very high
expectations and it surpassed them yeah
that is a rare occasion in my life like
it would be really sad if this wasn't a
special movie and while I was watching
it I was like this feels like a special
movie yeah yeah you know good for them
it's a pretty great almost it's a
masterpiece it's a masterpiece better
definitely better than ex I think I
think it's a masterpiece for sure I
think it's yeah it's a really well done
movie I mean if you want to go if you
want to like nitpick it or anyway fine
but if you want to just break it down in
terms of a [__] comic book movie yeah
this is a masterpiece yeah compar it to
the genre yeah I would say it's a comic
book Masterpiece for sure I really think
it's up there with like The Dark Knight
I really do definitely without a doubt
not like they're the same movie at all
but it's I think it's up there in terms
of its rawness and feeling just like a
film not a comic book movie yeah this
movie is what it needs to be and it's
responsible with all the things that it
has you know and it and it shows you
that the genre can be wider and it can
give you all the stuff that you want but
also give you things that are going to
you know maybe make you cry a little bit
you know like and yeah like that's
that's the most exciting thing to me
about this kind of movie is like I'll
gladly show up for [__] Wolverine
emotions yeah to throw down I cheered at
the end I I'm as much as I do reactions
I'm a rather quiet movie
Watcher like I when I watch movies I
tend to just I'll laugh along but I
rarely I rarely just feel the need to go
yeah yeah like I cheered like in the
finale at one point like I was just like
it's coming out of me man it's exciting
yeah what was the moment there was one
moment like you laughed really hard at
do you remember what that
was there was something that we laughed
at for like a couple cycles of laughter
I don't remember there's a few funny
moments yeah I don't think this film's
like filled with humor but it takes this
time to have humor like every 10 to 15
minutes like like oh good we got a
little joke here yeah well yeah there's
a lot of subtle stuff too like there's a
lot of Inplay and stuff like you really
get the sense that these people are
together all the time
yeah it's just I and I love characters
of people just trying to keep their [__]
together yeah and I love those kind of I
feel like sesi films have characters
like that all the time and people just
trying to keep [__] together and that's
like what Hugh Jackman's do in this
whole movie trying to keep everything
together you
know well he does a good job all right
well we'll finally wrap this up
subscribe to the real reject this supp
to be a short non-spoiler review but how
can you problem with some YouTube
reviews I'm like how how can you really
just tell someone what this is like in
like a few minutes like no I got I want
to express my emotion here this is this
is this was a very worthwhile film yeah
I think so I think definitely you know
it's it's going to give you even if it's
not your jam cuz it's not like you know
it's not always my jam like this is the
one I would tell you if if you're not in
love with the idea just still go see
this because this is Cinema it's its
only drawback is that you have to have
seen some other X-Men films like where
as opposed to The Dark Knight I don't
feel like you necessarily need to see
Batman Begins I think it makes the Dark
Knight better if you see Batman Begins
but I think the dark Knight's a great
Standalone film
Logan actually you know what I feel like
I feel like h no you need to know a
little bit about mutant and [__] well
yeah the thing is like it could still be
a compelling movie in that Western kind
of way where like I think it would make
you want to watch the other X-Men films
I think it would certainly do that yeah
yeah it's like you these aren't unlike
characters you would meet in certain
situations in you know an older Western
you know it it still introduces you to
what Logan's life is like now and the
situations he gets into and what you
know Charles's life is like like it
jumps you back into all that stuff in a
natural way and it doesn't pull too many
events without any kind of identifying
context so like I think you could still
definitely enjoy it but it'll always be
more special if you've seen them all
because like the thing is for this is
like we love Wolverine or a lot of
people do and we've watched this guy in
good movies and not so good movies and
one really not good movie and you know a
couple better movies and and so like
we've come a long way and so like it's
possible it it'll always be different if
you're watching it with the love of
Wolverine
or just as a film true but I think it
works both ways which is perfect all
right well subscribe to the real Rex
John is reasons to Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram a social media manager of
blumhouse and the real Rejects and shout
out to Tony Gil who's been sing in this
hot Corner TGI Friday 27 minutes over
here chilling
chilling hashtag
chilling there's only one thing I forgot
to do in this whole review ready
John hey
Bub he doesn't call anyone bub in this
movie I know he doesn't he does he
doesn't at all he doesn't call anyone
bub and he never shouts Jean he never
shouts Jean they don't even mention
J